welcome to the Siemens sinem Eric Webb
anar series today we're going to take a
look at shop floor programming we're
calling a chop for programming 101 for
shop mill for milling
today I will be your presenter Chris
and the virtual technical
application center manager and a
resource here for you guys to reach out
to if you have any questions or require
any assistance with operation and
programming based topics the contact
information is here in front of you feel
free to reach out if you have any
questions regarding this in America
product line so today we're going to
take a look at content specific to both
the a twenty eight and the eight forty
control so anything we talked about here
can apply to both control platforms
equally the intention of today's webinar
is to give you a really solid
understanding of our shop mill interface
which can certainly be used for shop
floor programming scenarios we're going
to take a look at making holes using
some standard cycles we're going to do
some pocketing some profile milling get
a chance to see thread milling and even
slotting cycles and then we'll even add
some additional functionality like
incorporating optional stops or program
stop commands to an existing part
program
we're going to kind of break down a
couple different topic areas we're going
to first take a look at the shop mill
interface as an overview and as we're
doing that we're going to collectively
build a live programming example
together so we're going to go through
common operations we're going to
leverage some of the cycles that we just
talked about in a real live example and
then once we're all said and done we're
going to start to take a look at some
additional functionality adding to the
part program to just kind of streamline
different features or functions so
before we begin first thing I'd like to
always point out is where I can go for
additional reference material and
certainly we would get into the shop
mill or shop turn programming
environments we have some some very
handy manuals that have been developed
and are available to you for download
this is a completely public web site you
can go in and you can search a whole
host of different content that Siemens
has available for you it is a very large
site so I certainly recommend if you're
going to go in and you know specifically
a topic you're looking for you want to
search for it so in this case we want to
look at the city train easy milling with
shop mill manual you get to that and
it's got some real great core
programming examples how to start
applying it and really kind of supports
and backs up a lot of the material we're
talking about today so as I said we're
going to be doing a live example while
we are going through the interface and
talking about the functionality so here
is a basic operations list of what we're
going to be doing so we're going to
certainly do some face milling as our
first op just data being the top of our
part we're going to go back we're going
to square up our feature we use some
profiling on the outside
once you've profile it we're going to
come in and do some pocketing features
so you're going to get a chance to see
us machine a circular pocket with that
three-inch counter bore and then a
through hole all the way through it's a
basically one inch a little less because
we're going to thread mill a one inch
eight thread through the center this
part will also do some drilling and
tapping features get a chance to see
a bunch of different operations there
we're going to be both drilling and
tapping on the peripheral four holes and
we're going to be through drilling and
then coming into machining some slots
and then we're all said and done we want
to go back and show you how to do some
deburring operations by using the built
in chance / functionality into the
control so what we're going to do here
is I'm going to use a piece of software
called cine train and sinew train allows
me to basically mimic or emulate a
machine tool control right here on my PC
so everything I do in this Cinna train
virtual world would be the same process
steps you would take when you get out
onto the machine now the first step is
to know where you need to go to start
writing our programs specifically
shuttle programs so you are always going
to want to find the program manager
button that can be seen either as a hard
key on your front panel or if you use
the menu select key you can also access
it through a soft key on the horizontal
keypad we're gonna get to show you both
as we switch over to sinew train from
there you're going to get into the
program manager field or area and that's
really kind of like for lack of a better
term kind of like Windows Explorer for
Siemens or force in America so this is
where you're going to save your core
programs will create new part programs
this is where you can manage external
memory whether you want to access a
network drive or any additional
peripheral memory you may have on the
control once we get in we're going to
select a new part program once we decide
what folder we want to place it in and
then from there we're going to start
creating a part program in shop mill now
shop mill and shop turn is our
conversational programming environment
it is an option and would require the
option to be already set up on your
machine now if you don't happen to have
it on your machine tool don't worry you
can add it if you'd like and the option
number is there on the bottom of the
screen general is a pretty simple piece
of software to add into the system it's
really just a matter of activating it
and it should be up and running
okay from there we're going to move on
to the next step which will be starting
to write our part program first thing
you're going to see when we start a new
program is what we call our program
header and the header just really sets
up a lot of the modal commands that will
be active through the length of the part
program so we're going to go in detail
we're going to build it specific to our
job but you're going to do things like
obviously tell it the unit of measure am
i an inch or my America
what we're corn am I using you're going
to set up some peripheral or perimeter
perimeter dimensions for our blank and
that's going to work with our simulation
or our graphics and then we're going
tell a little bit about our tool
orientation and some retrack strategies
once you've done that once you've
accepted the program header then you're
going to drop into what we call our
program editor and this is how it's
going to look like right at the control
so what you're going to see is you're
going to see the header the program
header and that's always going to be the
first line of the part program and then
from there as we add events or insert
events and an event would be an
operation like a pocket pill or a drill
or something along those lines you going
to see events start get placed basically
between the program header and the end
of program event until you have your
entire operations built now we have a
series of what we call soft keys and we
have horizontal and vertical soft keys
so those are those perimeter buttons
that you see the Edit the drill the
milling the contra mill or on the
vertical side build group find mark cut
copy paste so this is what we call soft
keys to called soft keys because they're
soft or driven and that's how you're
going to navigate through all the
functionality that can be found within
the program editor for shop mail now we
try not to have you have to get too too
far in or too many layers deep so you're
going to find usually it's only one or
two clicks to get into where you need
your appropriate operation so from there
the first soft key we're going to talk
about a little bit is the Edit function
and edit allows us to kind of do that
we're going to modify or change some of
the state of the part program
potentially so this is where you'll find
your cut copy and paste commands we have
additional commands like build group
which we're going to look at later from
there you can use the the lowest most
vertical soft key and that's that
vertical soft key that has the five
lines and then the arrow command and
that key allows you to expand the
vertical soft keys if there's more
options there than we're able to show if
we have more functions and we're able to
have keys for we use that lower button
and then that's going to change the
rotoscope keys so like you're seeing on
the right side of the screen that's what
that vertical bar would flip to so from
there you get functions like view or
graphic view that allow you to
either a wireframe of the part that you
think you're creating you can add
sequence numbers when I look at that a
little later or you can even open
further programs so if you had written a
program that's very similar to the part
program that you're making and you want
to move maybe events back and forth you
can copy and paste between programs they
can all be done in this section so for
us what we need to do is we need to
start writing our program we need to
give it a name just like we said we need
to get into this header and then we're
going to fill out the header so we're
going to fill out the header based on
specific information to our job so with
that being said why don't we switch over
to cine train and take a look at what it
would take to start writing this program
so here I have senior train sitting in
our jog environment this would be the
area that you'd be familiar with if
you're going to set up or just move
around the machine now I mentioned
earlier first thing I have to do is get
to the program manager screen so if I
look at my hard keys I will see in my
nine hard keys I have just above my blue
arrow keys there is a program manager
button program manager is going to
automatically paste me into the program
manager area if you don't have a program
manager hard key or you can't find it
for any reason you're going to font your
look for the menu select button the menu
select will give us soft equivalent keys
of these hard keys and there I'm going
to see on the horizontal soft key the
button called program manager that's the
same as the hard key now if you're
looking at your machine there's a lot of
new touchscreen driven machines these
days and maybe you don't see the menu
select key either
well if you have the M button up top
that performs as the menu select key so
I can also touch the appropriate portion
of the screen where it shows my M and
the M would also act as a menu select
button so depending on the configuration
we do have a lot of different front
panel variants you can do one of those
three things but if you happen to have
it certainly the simplest thing is to
press the hard key for program manager
and that's going to bring us in the
program
environment now once you're here first
you're going to see that you're in what
we call NC memory that's the internal
memory and you can navigate up and down
through our tree so in NC we have three
primary folders as I see right here on
my display I have the part program
folder and in there I would have part
programs with an extension MP f stands
for main program file I can create sub
programs or I can go to a workpiece
directory and I can create subfolders
and have all kinds of different file
extensions in those sub folders your
part program really could be in any of
these folders typically it's common to
place them up in the part program
directory if you have additional memory
areas you could potentially have what we
call local Drive that's expanded memory
on the machine you could be creating
programs on a USB stick or you may have
a button here along the horizontal soft
keys that would be a network drive
so again pick the appropriate folder you
want to create programs in as long as a
highlight is just somewhere within the
folder either on the name or somewhere
in it then if you select my new vertical
soft key I'll be creating a program
inside that folder
yeah just like we saw on the slide I'm
going to choose the shot mail option as
long as I have the option or the license
option on my machine tool and then I'm
going to give it a name so in this case
I'm going to call my program sample one
now when it comes to naming a program
you can use letters you can use
underscores and you can use the
numerical values can't use any other
characters outside of that so if you
wanted to do a forward slash or a
decimal point it's going to tell you
invalid character now you don't have to
give the extension system is going to
automatically assign it so just remember
letters numbers and underscores from
there select the okay and it's going to
launch the program now this is where
we're seeing the header page that I
showed you and I mentioned so we can
come in and we can start to fill out our
header page now what does our program
look like well I did show you quick
representation of it before but I just
wanted to bring up with the
it looks like so in our case we're going
to be machining a block it's going to
finish at a width of five inches and a
height of four inches it's going to
finish one inch thick so I'm going to be
machined this from probably something a
little larger I do want to go around and
machine the perimeter and make sure it's
to size into tolerance and square now
I'm going to be doing some internal
features now first question I see on my
screen is going to be what my unit of
measure is so that would most likely be
what is my program in dimension Daz so
this is an inch part it's an inch print
so I'm going to keep the Machine in inch
mode on any of these fields if I need to
change them what I'm going to do is I'm
going to use the Select key that's this
little blue key in the middle of all my
arrows with the little egg horseshoe
look and by hitting select I can toggle
between my two options now here if you
forget and you move your cursor around
and you're hovering over a field if you
see in the little pop-up that little
horseshoe come up that's again reminding
you that by placing the pressing the
Select key you can toggle or change the
field in addition if I hit any key on my
keyboard anyone I want it'll also give
me a pop-up and I can pull down so we
set up our unit of measure now I'm going
to set up a work corner I was going to
use for this job next I need to tell the
system what I want to use as far as the
part shape now this is only a primitive
that's going to be used for simulation
purposes it's not going to change the
actual resulting tool path so here we
support cylinders cylinders holes in
them as a pipe basic blocks with the
center being 0 0 a block with two
opposing corners being my datum I
support multi-site of stock and then if
I don't want any graphics I could leave
it at a value of none so in our case
we're using a basic block because if I
look at my print I'll see that my part 0
is in the upper left-hand corner of my
part so I don't want to establish the
center in this case I'm going to use
maybe that's my back fix jaw so we'll
use that as the part now
let's say for argument's sake looking at
the part we're going to say that the
rough stock on machining this problem is
maybe a quarter inch oversized so five
and a quarter by four and a quarter so
potentially I'm going to want to
accommodate for that to kind of Center
my part within my stock so when we come
to come over and we touch off that edge
whether I use a part probe or an edge
finder I'm going to leave a little
material on the left side the top side
when I touch off so that's the same
thing I'm going to do here when I'm
setting up the model I'm just telling it
two opposing corners either one in my
case I'm using the upper left-hand
corner and the lower right or I could
use the lower left upper right it
doesn't matter or go backwards so I'm
telling it that I'm going to have an
eighth inch of stock on one side because
remember we're going to finish it five
inch so I mean my stock would be overall
a five and a quarter so I want to take
half of that material or an eighth so
I'm going to tell it that my X datum or
reference my starting point is going to
be a minus 125 and the Y is going to be
a plus 125 then my over all opposing
corner which in this case I'm describing
the lower right-hand corner of my stock
is going to be five and a quarter or
five and a trellis excuse me buy this
four and 1/8 now you see how I have the
absolute symbol to the right of these
commands whenever I see that that means
that I can change the dimension from an
absolute or an incremental value I'm
going to do it the same way I'm going to
use the Select key to toggle between
those two fields so if you don't see
anything written to the side of it
that's immediately telling you that that
field or that input field is an absolute
value you can't change it or it could be
an unsigned value depending on the
operation but again it's not editable
it's not changeable it's a fixed value
top on my stock once I've described my
two opposing corners and those the
length and width it needs to have
thickness now in this case I did say I
was going to take a facing cut so I'm
going to leave a little material for a
facing kind of leaving 30,000 then I'm
giving it some overall thickness now I'm
saying I'm grabbing by a 1/4 of an inch
from the bottom of the part it's going
to be taken off a little
later I can set that to an absolute or
an incremental value I'm going to make
it an absolute value maybe maybe I make
it a little less maybe we're only
holding it by a 125 so we got an inch
and an eighth okay then you have your
default tool plane so this is going to
control what the canned cycle knows the
z axis orientations to be so I can set
it to G 17 18 or 19 so let's say you
have a right angle head you can tell
here in a G 18 orientation and now
you're drilling cycles would actually
drill in that orientation or I'm going
to stay in my standard G 17 plane for a
vertical machine retract where do I go
when I'm done with the physical cycle or
mine or me even my in the program once
I'm done in any operation where do I
retract to and then your safety distance
is how close do you wrap it to a surface
before you start feeding so right now
we're wrapping or wrapping into a
hundred thousand surface this is an
unsigned value or an incremental value
now you do have your machining state and
that's really do I want to climb Miller
conventional mill so down cut is going
to refer to climb milling up cut is
going to refer to conventional milling
and if you watch our little animated
element you can see if you forget which
is which as long as you know the
difference between climb mill and
conventional mill you can see it right
on the screen
final question we're drilling they have
multiple planes do I want to send the
Machine always up to my retrack plane
every time no too rapid back and forth
but it will move way up to in this case
one inch above the part or do I want the
system optimize and only retract when is
necessary so you'll know that based on
the type of program you're creating if
you had a lot of clamps in the way you
might want to gear to the safe side and
always retract to the retract plane now
once an event like this is been filled
out properly you're now going to hit the
accept key and that's going to save the
event into the program and now show us
the editor like we're seeing from the
graphics before from there we're going
to use these peripheral buttons the
horizontal soft keys and then the
vertical soft keys to build our program
so currently we only have one event
created which is our header they still
there's a little arrow command here
that's just telling you that if you hit
the blue arrow to the right you can
reopen the event make any changes you
want hit accept if you want to save it
cancel if you want to just jump back out
and continue program so that's what that
little arrow means that's how you edit
any event so as you create more we could
always go back in and edit them
okay so once we've certainly started the
program now you're going to decide well
what am I going to do what kind of
tooling or what kind of operations am I
going to need to do to start to make
this part so in our case we're going to
do some milling first so I figured we
kind of jump over drilling for a moment
and we'll segue into the milling section
so in milling you have a whole series of
camp cycles we're going to be
specifically looking at the face mill
the pocket and the spigot command in our
case we're also going to get a chance to
use a slot math read mill but just to
give you kind of an overview one of the
only cycles we're not going to get into
in this webinar is the engraving cycle
specifically but you'll find that the
cycles are very intuitive so once you've
gone through a couple of them you can
pretty much figure out what we're asking
in any of these variables so in our
cases we want to go in and we want to
create a facing tool path so we're going
to use the milling horizontal soft key
and then they'll see the vertical soft
key is going to pop up and it's going to
give me the face milling button by
selecting that button we'll then go in
to our input screen and we're going to
fill out the page from top to bottom and
just kind of answer each question as
they come when we're all said and done
we save it we're going to see that face
milling event will have been inserted
just below my program header and
starting to give me some operations in
my part program so moving back over to
send you train we're in the program
editor we're going to select the milling
horizontal soft key then we're going to
go up to the upper face mill a vertical
soft key and that's going to allow us to
access this cycle
now once we've entered in to a physical
cycle we're going to kind of want to
just fill out the cycle from top to
bottom kind of like it's just each edge
options there's a question so the first
thing I see the very top of the screen
is what tool do you want to use for this
operation so at this point you want to
select a tool from the tool library now
you may not have a tool array created so
we are going to go build one I'm going
to show you how that whole process works
so when you're on the tool field and you
see it's an orange you want to use the
Select tool key in the upper right hand
corner that's going to give you a quick
little reference of your existing tool
changer now if you don't have any tools
created what you're going to do is
you're going to hit the tool list button
again now in the upper end corner it's
the same button just change the labeling
a little bit and that's going to drill
us all the way back or drive us all the
way back to our offset table so now
you're just going to go down to an
appropriate spot where you want to
create a tool excuse me and we're going
to use the new tool button to actually
build that tool so by selecting new tool
you can now access an entire tool
library that we have available from
creating end Mills face mill what you're
going to do right now all sorts of
different drills if you don't see the
tool you're looking for then take a look
in some of the other areas so cutters
drill special tools as all kinds of
tools available normally in most cases
you'll find what you're looking for in
the favorites field so in our case we're
going to come down to the face mill or
facing tool to create a face mill select
okay machine's going to build that tool
type now it may give you a suggested
name and all depends on of the
parameters turned on or not or just give
you a blank in my case I'm going to
leave the facing tool recommended name
I'm going to call them on a three-inch
facing tool from there you're going to
hit the input button and move your
cursor over I'm going to give it just a
default length just to have something
from a simulation perspective you're
going to touch these tools off later so
I'm going to give it to the negative 15
inch sir
you can be using positive or negative to
link ducts that's either one is up to
you then you're going to give it the
diameter so this would be saying that my
cutter cutting path is going to be a
3-inch diameter when I come over to the
Enfield that's a number of flutes or a
number of teeth on the tool so let's say
this is a five five insert shell mill my
direction is important that would be the
direction of spindle rotation and
whether I want a coolant to be turned on
or off for this visit visible physical
tool you'll notice inside of shot mill
you don't drive the coolant commands or
the spindle direction it all gets driven
from this tool additionally if more
information is required you may see a
further data button pop up and this just
fills out the rest of the information
about a tool so if I happen to have a
face mill that's got a 45 degree angle
to the tool so the actual body is bigger
than three inch we can tell the system
that here and now if we send this tool
up to a wall it's going to know how big
it's true diameter is and then stay away
from the wall accordingly once you fill
that the additional information just hit
the back key and now you can hit to
program and what the system is going to
do is it's going to take the tool name
that you created and insert it right
into the tool field from there we're
going to move on we're give it to give
it some speeds and some feeds so from
our fear a perspective just like we saw
before I can select basically whether I
want to be in feed per minute in this
case inches per minute or I can use the
Select key with the horseshoe and toggle
it to feed per tooth so the system can
actually calculate feed rate for you
based on the parameters of feed per
tooth and then when you get to rpm you
can do rpm or you can set constant
service speeds so if I look at my insert
pack and for a given recommended
material maybe it says that I want to
run at a surface footage of three and a
half now
tooth iro shows you a feed four to three
and a half now and a
purpose footage of let's say 1804 that
tool in that material now if I come back
and I select or toggle back to the feed
rate system will even show me the
calculated feeds and speeds for those
cutter scenarios or come cutter
parameters excuse me
so with that being said you can leave it
in either field it's really kind of up
to you if you want to leave it at Beaver
tooth or feed per minute and symptom
with car service speed or rpm next
option next field is machining or
machining since state so what do we want
to do so a single diamond refers to a
roughing operation that would mean that
I'd have multiple cuts in Z triple
triple diamond would refer to a finished
operation now in this scenario I just
want to take all 30 file so I'm going to
leave it at a finish op I can control my
cutter direction with this little symbol
right here so I can change it from a
bi-directional tool path to a
unidirectional tool path or I can do a
bi-directional and Y or unidirectional
in Y then it's a matter of just filling
out some basic parameters so whenever I
see the X Y or Z zero field this is what
we call our datum for the cycle so
basically I need to give it some
parameters that the cycle is working
within now these values will
automatically filled out for you based
on the header page this is the only
cycle that actually pulls data from the
header page so that's where it came up
with the negative 1/8 by positive 1/8
the positive 35 because I gave that the
header page and the overall length and
width now what it didn't do and you just
want to make sure you have the right
value in here is where do I want to end
that's where my x y&z one represent
right XY Z that's kind of a starting
position and this is the ending position
to describe the shape that I'm cutting
so in my case I want to end at a value
of z0 now I can control my radial engage
member my step over again using the
horseshoe I can toggle between a linear
distance or a percentage of the cutter
myself I like to use a percentage of the
cutter this way if I change my tool my
radial engagement will change to
whatever the new tool sizes now whenever
you see a u that's referring to a
Finnish amount so any value I leave here
is going to be kept away if I'm in a
roughing scenario or in the Finnish will
be used just to calculate what the
material would be left for a lead-in
let's say so in this case we don't we're
going to just tell it where at zero
we're just bringing everything right to
plane we accept or save when we see the
event kits inserted
so once we've faced off the part then we
have some profile mailing to do right
next logical step in any part would be
to date on the top of the part and then
kind of square it up so we're going to
do is we're going to come in here we're
going to use two cycles because in this
case I wanted to rough and finish the
outside of the the part let's say for
argument's sake my geometric tolerance
my dimensions are pretty tight or I just
surface qualities of an issue so
whenever I leave material from a
roughing cycle I do have to remember to
take it off with another event with
using the triple diamond to represent
the finish pass once we've added those
we're then going to get a chance to use
our simulator function so the simulation
is going to bring up a 3d model and
actually allow me to see a tool moving
around in space now when looking at the
vertical soft keys that get launched
once you hit the simulation button upper
right-hand corner is going to be cycle
start and reset below that I can change
my view orientation so top view would be
me looking down as if I'm looking at in
the g17 orientation plane the 3d
function is an option so if you don't
have it you can always be headed to
control but this allows me to get full
3d simulation and if I happen to be on a
four or five axis machine tool we can
actually simulate five axes in this mode
or I can use my further views and look
at the system from the left or the right
side of my orientation so from there
we're going to transition over to Cindy
train and continue writing the program
now if we bring up the print let me pop
that up here real quick I'm going to
need to machine around the perimeter and
then finish that up so I'm going to use
we'll create a tool maybe a three
corners tool to come in remember I have
an eighth of an inch of material around
the part and I also want to put in this
nice corner radius which is a 250 radius
so we are in the editor or highlight is
sitting on the face mill so it's going
to insert below I want to make sure I'm
in the milling function if I'm not I'm
gonna hit the milling button and then I
want to choose my spigot and again
spigot the multi-head spigot is
going to frame milling or boss smelly
most commonly referred to now when we
come into the cycle if you see the
option for complete or simple that's
just going to reduce the number of
variables on the screen so sometimes
when you're first learning it's nice to
maybe switch it to a simple and just
concentrate on what the immediate stuff
I have to fill out is we're going to
leave it all a complete for these
examples now when you go into the cycles
I want to pick the vertical sake that
represents the shape I'm machining so is
it a rectangular circular or multi-sided
spigot or boss so for our case it's a
rectangular now I'm going to come down
and start filling out the operations now
in this case the last time the cycles
used is left of the chamfering up so I
can jump down and I can change that to a
roughing operation if I want and now I'm
just going to see that it looks more
like a traditional roughing scenario
first question is going to be what tool
am I using for machining this out so I'm
going to go to the Select tool I'm going
to go back to my tool list because we
need to create a new tool so now in
Pocket 3 I'm just going to build a new
tool it's going to be an N mill and I'm
going to call this my cutter 3/4 of an
inch so that's my 3/4 of an inch end
mill again give it a basic length I'll
keep the same lengths for this example
for now when we get to Rayleigh run it
the part you'll have to obviously set
these going to give the system my tool
diameter now you want to pay attention
to the symbol on the top of the page if
this doesn't have a diameter symbol this
could be radial so it's really a machine
parameters up to the Builder whether it
wants to set them up to be a radius
value or diametric value this one's set
up for diameter
how many floats one two three whether I
want my coolant my direction you see I
get no further data means I'm done
there's no other information I need to
worry about at this point
we select the to program button fills
out the new name now the d1 that get
filled out automatically for me in this
case I'm only creating one offset for
the tool we do have the ability to
advance their script multiple offices
for a tool and that's where the D number
would come in - that would correlate to
the physical D column in the office of
table so if you create multiple offsets
you'll see a d2 d3 d4 all the way up to
potentially d9 but when you're just
building your first tool that's always
going to be at a d1 okay feed rate again
just like we showed paper to speed per
minute same thing with rpm toggle
between them now the reference point we
didn't have to do in the face aside what
we do here and this really has to do
with the datum location where do I want
that to be relative to join I want it to
be relative to some corner because
that's where my dimensions came from or
do I want to be relative to the middle
of the feature now this isn't the part
but this is the feature the in this case
the spigot now in our scenario it
happens to be one of the same because
we're machining around the perimeter of
the part so I'm going to leave it at the
center and then when I come down to do
my x 0 y 0 that's going to be working
off the middle of the part I do need to
tell it if I'm roughing finishing or
you'll notice in this operation we even
have the chamfer option which we'll do
later in a rough if you see single
position or pattern that just means that
if I had to do multiples of this
operation
so let's say it was a pocket and they
needed to do 10 in a row I could link
this to locations just like I do a
drilling cycle and then it would machine
10 pockets in a row for me in our case
if I'm just doing one I want to leave it
at single position we tell it where the
center datum feature is of the part
because of where our reference point was
left so mines two and a half inch over
two inch down according to my print top
of the part 0 my rough stock so remember
four and a quarter by five and a quarter
now this is just going to control my
lead-in and lead-out move on to the part
my finished dimensions a four inch by
five inch block
my corner radius which is on my print is
250 so we would type in a value of 250
here if my part feature was tipped at an
angle or not mine is not so I'm going to
leave it at 0 the overall depth of my
part so I know it's going to go to at
least one inch my depth per pass so
maybe I want to take this in two passes
so I'm going to give it a value of 0.5
and then as we said before in a roughing
operation if I have au value this is the
material it's going to leave on for me
to come back and take a finishing
operation on so I'm going to in this
case leave tenth bow on the X&Y walls of
my part but I'm not going to worry about
coming back and finishing the Z bottom
because at some point I know this is
going to get faced off so we fill out
the page we hit accept that inserts it
now below the facing cycle now in our
case we got to jump back in and we got
to give it a finish pass so if I just
come straight back to the multi-edge
spigot you'll notice the system retains
all the information that I just plugged
in so I don't have to type it all over
again it's going to always leave the
values that were that we're just last
entered into the field so in my case
maybe I want to slow down my feed rate
or kick up my spindle because it's a
finish pass I do want to tell the system
I am doing a finished pass and then I
want to come down and I want to tell it
maybe I don't want to do multiple finish
passing that you could come right down
the surface I could do two or three or
four finish passes in the Z or if you
set the depth of cut which is what our
DZ represents two equal to at least the
total depth or more you can go larger it
is just go right down to the bottom
it'll never exceed the z1 field
before we had a value here that was
telling us to how much material to leave
on the part now we want to leave this
value because this is what's going to
control our lead-in if we set it to zero
you may not have enough material for the
system to calculate what the lead-in is
so I'm going to leave my tenth ow and if
you start to increase that number you
can see it would just change the ramp in
move on this this feature so we fill out
the page we hit accept now we get our
rough our finish so at this point we can
now simulate we could take a look at our
simulation package so if I hit the
simulate simulation button system is
going to come in it's going to start our
simulation while we are just on a top
view so I'm going to see my cutter come
around the top there I can see my
multiple depths of cut and my final
finish pass since we have it we look at
it in a 3d we can use the cycle start
button to restart it and now we can see
it machine the feature in 3d
and as I mentioned you could also use
further views and looking from a front
view back view right view and then I can
back up and maybe go back to my 3d view
so here we can start to see it's
starting to look like our part program
okay so once I've squared up my part
next logical operation based on my part
print is going to be my pocketing cycle
so in the pocket we've got a couple
things we're going to do first thing I'm
going to do is I'm going to pocket out
that through-hole that basically that
one inch through-hole it's a little less
900 mil the part and then I'm going to
come back in and we're going to do the 3
inch counter bore so we're going to
rough out the pocket the center pocket
we're going to rough out the three inch
counter bore then we're going to do a
finish pass on that three inch counter
bore so at the end result we're going to
get three separate events to handle
coring out the center of the material so
as we transition over to Sydney train we
can start to add in those events let me
bring up the print so you can kind of
keep an eye on it so first we're going
to again machine this center pocket so
if I look at the pocket print this this
physical hole is going to be a 1 inch 8
thread so if I wanted to go in we could
certainly check in the machinist
handbook here it's giving me an 875
through so that would be what I would
want to machine that bore through so we
want to go to milling and if you come
into the blast event that's ok just hit
cancel we don't need another rectangle
pocket because in our case we want to go
to a circular pocket instead of a
rectangular spigot like we were just in
so select the Pocket vertical soft key
and then again remember I got to pick
which one I want to do so it defaults to
a rectangular pocket initially but here
I can go into a circular pocket as well
just by clicking the vertical soft key
and now we're going to fill out the page
so if I want to use the same tool I just
used which in our case was a 3
jamil I certainly can for all this I
don't have to keep picking the three
corners tool if it's there you can leave
it but for its a modal command so again
you don't have to keep picking that tool
I'm going to leave it blank we're going
to give it some feeds and speeds same
rule applies as before I'm going to
choose my operation in this case I want
to rough now in circular I got two
different machining strategies I get
helical which will do a helix all the
way the bottom kind of like a thread
routine or I can do a call plane by
plane so we're going to show you both
first one I'm going to do is a helix
especially when you get to deep hole
pocketing I get much better chip
evacuation when I'm using a helix in
this case - I don't have a lot of
peripheral material to take out really
the material I'm machining is more deep
than it is wide so this works as a great
strategy for that single positioner
pattern just like I showed you before
we're going to use a single position
what is the center of my pocket our
parts two and a half over two and a half
down or two inch down what is the top of
the pocket in this case it's starting at
zero zero top of my part the diameter is
0.8 75 according to my print
the through-hole is be how far I want to
go and this can be an absolute or may
incremental value remember whenever I
have this field that means I can use my
select key to toggle it in our case I
want to go probably just to get through
the part so if I know the part is an
inch and a four maybe I'll go 130
remember it's an inch and an eighth
because that's what I told it was for
the rough stock in the header page what
do I want my radial engagement to be so
she's going to helix down and then if it
didn't have enough based on the diameter
of the tool and the tool path she's
going to then step over 25 percent of
cover cutter and he looks again until it
achieves this outside diameter the
p-value that would be my lead-in pitch
so you'll have to know how aggressive
with the tool you're using the ramp in
can be I'm using an eighth of an inch
per revolution might be a little
aggressive in some tools so you
certainly want to use the recommended
feed-in angle of that given tool but the
center cutting tool you can get pretty
aggressive with it so I want to leave
material for finish cut so we're going
to bring everything right to size so I'm
going to say no so in this case I'm just
going to hit accept and that's going to
put in my circular pocket now I want to
come in and I want to do my counter bore
so I'm just going to go right back to
pocket I'm in my circular pocket still
it retained all my values now I'm just
going to change what I need to change so
we're still roughing but I do want to do
a centric or a plane by plane machining
strategy now so here it's going to come
down to my first step to pass machine
all the way out to the three inch
- whatever materiality for a finish cut
and then move down again my next step
and continue on single position stays
the same Center my pocket stays the same
top of my pockets the zero that's good
but my diameter is actually going to be
three inch per my print
so we're machinee to a three inch
counter bore the depth is in shown in my
sectional view is going to be in half
inch deep so I'm going to give it -
point five
my step over maybe we're going to do 50%
of the cutter diameter my depth for
passed so let's say we want to take it
in two passes I'm going to say 125 for
my depth for pass do I want to leave
material for a finish cut sure so we can
leave 10th on the wall and if I wanted
to make sure it's a nice clean bottom
maybe I'll leave 10,000 the bottom as
well
now this helical is it going to machine
a roll out this is just the ramp in so
you get a couple rampant strategies in
this case I can do a helix or a plunge
vertical plunge vertical would actually
work fine in this area because I already
know there's a hole in it but if there
wasn't a hole you would certainly want
to use a helical ramp in you do need to
tell it how aggressive your your lead or
your revolution is going to be this is
going to be your lead-in depth so per
Rev how far you advance and then what's
the radius that you're revolving about
now we have another option called
removing you can use complete machining
or rima sheeting and what that does is
that allows us to accommodate if there's
a portion of this pocket feature that's
previously been machined whether it was
drilled or however it was machine so in
this case I don't need to waste time
trying to machine the center of it so I
can now tell it that okay a total of a
half inch material by 0.8 75 has been
removed now I know it the features
actually longer than that but the cycle
is not going to want you to give it a
depth any greater than the physical
cycle so if I tell it one-inch you see
that it's going to give me an alarm so
just go to the total depth if you know
that your feature that's been removed is
equal to or greater than that depth it
is an unsigned value you notice I'm not
giving it a negative in fact if you give
it a negative it's going to give you a
error message or an alarm and this is
our error message checking so typically
if you get through the cycle and get hit
accept
you're pretty good so we're going to
accept it now we're going to just jump
right back in to our circular pocket one
last time I'm going to take a finishing
cut and
now in this case I want to finish
everywhere the floor and the wall so I'm
just going to pick finish I can use the
same rampant strategy or if I wanted to
we could go to maybe a plunge I'm going
to just drop down at 20 inches a minute
till I'm at depth and then we're going
to clean the bottom and the wall of the
feature I'm leaving my previous values
this way she knows how much material is
left on the bottom and the side save the
event and now we can do a simulation and
start to see that we're moving right
along here
you
so there's our counterbore and here you
can see our finished cut so it finished
around the wall and finished the bottom
and the rest of the wall will go back to
the editor and now let's see what our
next operation is going to be
okay so once we've cleared it out now we
can start to drill some holes so whether
the drilling cycle you're going to see
there's a bunch of events there for me
or cycles there for me under drilling so
we're going to get a chance to use
centering drilling and deep hole
drilling but there are boring as well
boring cycle before a single point
boring head in this way if you have a
indexable or orientated spindle we can
actually orient the boring bar pull off
the wall pull out of the hole without
dragging the bar up along it it also
gives you a obviously a much more
optimized machining strategy for that
type of boring head as opposed to just
using like a drill reaming type of
operation and then we're going to use
the threading to do some tapping as well
as the pitches or position commands to
tell it where we're going to drill
so in our job we got a couple different
scenarios I got a senator drill some
holes so here you're going to get a
chance to see not only how I set up a
camp cycle but how I link the positions
as to where it's going to drill and in
our case we're going to get to drill on
a couple different planes so we're going
to drill around the top and then drill
down on our half inch pocket so you're
going to see how we get to handle that
type of feature so inside the sinew
train let's bring the print back up so
you keep an eye are going to have four
holes around the outside that we're
going to spot drill and then we're gonna
spot drill this bolt hole pattern that's
down a half inch deep so I want to go to
the drilling field again my highlight is
going to stay on my last stop so it's
always going to insert below and we're
going to pick the center drilling option
so in senator drilling I'm going to pick
a tool I don't happen to have a tool
created so I'm going to select new I do
have a center drill option so I'm going
to pick it now I'm going to say that
this Center drill is my 3/8 of an inch
center drill we're going to give it a
default length like we did before now I
don't necessarily need to define
obviously the cutter diameter of a drill
but I need it for simulation purposes so
it's not going to change the tool path
and all if I don't have it but I'm not
going to see it actually drill so I do
want to give it and then I want to give
it an accurate tip angle so in this case
I'm saying this Center drill is an I
agree now this isn't a combination
Center drill this is a true and C style
spot drill if I need my coolant
certainly remember the appropriate
spindle rotation say to program plugs in
the name fill-out speeds and feeds now
when you get to drilling it's not feed
per tooth but it's feed per Rev like you
would typically know right out of your
tooling catalog and it's still surface
footage or straight rpm so either
scenario you can use now when we get to
the depth option how do I want to
compensate for the depth I can
compensate based on the true tip now I
have to tell it how deep I need to drill
but what's nice about the center
drilling routine
as I can also tell it what the size of
my countersink is going to be and the
system will calculate the depth so
that's why it was so important for me to
put the appropriate angle so I type in a
spot diameter of 300 thou if I looked at
the print it would tell me it wants a
countersink of ninety degrees three
hundred thousand so that's what I was
looking to get perfect and then do I
want to dwell at the bottom so sometimes
if I'm breaking through it's nice to
give a little little dwell there it
except and now you can see something a
little different here we see this little
open-ended bracket that just means we
need a little bit more information so I
know how to drill I don't know where to
drill so that's we're going to use the
position buttons to describe where we're
going to drill so when you go into
positions we got a bunch of different
scenarios here we have random holes
which we're going to use for our for
outside holes but I can do a raise that
would be just a linear row of holes I
can do grids excuse me I can do a grid
of holes or a frame of holes and the
frame would actually work fine for this
scenario as well and then we can go into
bolt hole patterns complete bolt hole or
a partial
we're going to use the bolt on pattern
next so first it's going to random now
with random you're going to get nine
potential hole location starts at the
location of zero and goes up through
eight if you need more you can then save
as many of these events as you need in
our case I don't want to have any of the
numbers that were here so I can use the
delete all button to get rid of them I
do want to tell the plane at which I'm
drilling from so if you if you notice
before it knows the spot drill size but
it really doesn't know we're starting
from and that's you're going to tell
that right here in the cycle that's
saying that this set of holes is sitting
at Z zero come apart now you're going to
give it your coordinates so if I look at
the print my first hole is half an inch
over and mine is a half an inch down
next hole if I going to go straight over
to my right is going to be four and a
half inches over I'm not moving in my Y
so I can leave a blank now I'm coming
straight down in the Y to minus 3.5
that's going to put me at the lower
right hand corner hole now I'm going to
move back since I'm all absolute I'm
just going to move back to an absolute
position of 0.5 and I'm not moving the Y
so I'm going to leave that alone so now
I have four locations zero is my first
location one is my second two is my
third three is my fourth location once I
filled them in I can always look at
graphic view and then I get a nice
little wireframe of my part so far of my
operations and I can see my locations so
had I maybe had a typo I can see where
it would put the whole off the part so
it just gives you a quick representation
of where those holes are going to be I
hit accept you see it inserts the event
now I want to come into the ball tool
powder now this is a little different
because my bolt hole pattern is down
inside this pocket by half an inch so
that's where the z0 comes in handy I can
use the same can cycle as long as my
depths going to be the same on that
cycle and then I can just use a couple
different location strategies for where
the top of the part is so in this case
I'm going to put minus 0.5 then define
the center of the bolt hole pattern
angle of my first hole so a value of
zero would be three o'clock a value of
90 would go up to 12 o'clock and it goes
counterclockwise from there right so a
value of 180 puts me over at nine
o'clock the radius of my bolt hole
pattern came right off my print with
inch in 1/8 number of holes and then how
do I want to position between the holes
so I would just go shortest path or do I
want to follow the radius of the park'
so it was a boss or something in the way
it except holes are in if we simulate we
should now see it do some spot filling
for us so we face off now the simulation
is always going to start from beginning
there are ways to speed up simulation or
slow it down we'll see that in a second
but you can't easily start from the
middle
so there is our four spotted holes and
there are our spotted holes and if you
saw it it stayed down it didn't keep
jumping all the way back to the retrack
point until it was said and done okay
so if we go back to our operations we
now see we it's time to drill some of
these holes right so we're going to have
to do some deep hole drilling so we are
going to use the deep hole drilling
cycle because we're going to Peck drill
we're going to say that maybe you know
we don't threw coolant on this I want to
I want to pull out of the hole or I just
want to break the chip let's say so we
use the depot drilling to fully drill
for outside premier holes we're going to
use our tapping cycle and what's what's
interesting is the way we structure
things to kind of reduce the number of
events it would take to create a part if
you're doing multiple operations on the
same series of holes you can set up the
can cycles first so in this case I'm
going to do the drilling and then the
tapping and then tell the locations and
it will do all operations on those
locations now for our case I need to
redo the positions that were done during
the center drilling out so I'm going to
use the repeat positions function to go
back and reuse those now I could just do
those positions all over again but now
I'm managing the same geometry in
different locations and I don't want to
do that
so we're the highlight is I want to go
to drilling and I want to cancel out and
back up because I need to get to the
depot drilling operation now we're going
to fill out the depot drilling so we're
going to build a tool so I'm going to
cheat and use the name I had used
previously but in the tool library
actually have it yet so we're going to
create it so we'll build a new drill or
do a twist drill and we're going to call
it what's nice you can cut copy and
paste in all these areas so I'm going to
call it a number seven drill you know
it's a 15 inch length
it's a 201 drill and I want to know the
geometry so I'm going to assume I'm
using 180-degree tip to program make
sure it's filled out now just because
the name is here if it doesn't existence
what library you do have to build it
again so the shot metal interface isn't
going to necessarily delete the last
given name that was in here if you
deleted the tool that's just a reference
for you you can still do P per Rev or Z
per minute we're going to do feed per
minute same thing with our VMware con
service speed we have a couple different
chip removal operations so I'm chip
breaking or chip removal we also have a
deep hole drilling routine that would
allow me to accommodate a true deep hole
drilling where I need to pilot it and
then insert a long deep hole drill
slowly into the part before I start up
the spindle that's all accommodates this
deep hole drilling to cycle so the
standard Depot one is our traditional
deep hole drilling or Peck drilling or
chip breaking routine so we're going to
do a chip braking actually switch up
removal so we'll pull out the hole each
time how do I want to compensate for the
tip for the depth of the drill so if I
do shank the Z one value is actually
going to be at the edge of the tip and
then this way the system will actually
drill deeper than Z 1 by whatever it
calculates the tip projection to be
that's why it's so important for you to
give me the right geometry of the tip to
the drill if I said it's a tip now it's
only going to go down with
- whatever having z1 field so that's how
I can control so if I know I want to do
a breakthrough we have a depth of inch
and an eighth I can you shank and I
should get right through the hole my
first feed that's FD one so do I want to
go slower than the ten inches a minute
for that first and feed and then how far
in do I want the first in feed to be and
then from there the percentage of every
previous or following Peck so if I put a
percentage number in here it'll reduce
the D value as it pecks deeper deeper
deeper so if I'm getting a lot of chip
packing I might want to make that Peck
small or not be as aggressive as I was
when the flutes were certainly out of
hole how much do I want to back up and
then do I want to do a dwell at the
bottom fill out the page you hit accept
then we did mention we're going to tap
some holes so I can tell it that now I
do have to build a tap so I'm going to
go in to my tool list create a new tool
this is going to be a tap so pick the
tool tap right out of the library give
it some name for your reference I'm
going to call my own a quarter twenty
tap will just give it a default tool
length for now tool diameter and the
pitch the pitch if you're an inch is
going to be the threads per inch so it's
going to be twenty and so no matter how
I program the physical pitch in the
tapping cycle if the machines sitting an
inch then the tool table the tap has to
be built as threads per inch the machine
sitting in metric this becomes the true
metric pitch so like a six by one I
would put a value of one here in the
table okay we can define the geometry by
some pre-built tables or I can leave a
table off and now under the pitch field
I can use my select key and I can toggle
between a bunch different thread
geometry types so I can do threads per
inch I can do a module Oh thread I can
program a metric pitch even though I'm
in an inch program I can give it an inch
pitch now if you're doing threads per
inch and you don't need to fry
should just remember to cancel it out so
if there's a number here I'll just do 0
over 100 then this is 20 threads per
inch if I was doing 20 and a half I can
put 21 to and that will give me 20 half
threads
my rpm right she's going to calculate
the feed that's a constant based on the
55 pitch of my thread but my rpm is up
to me so in this case I'm going to come
in at 500 rpm and retract at the same
rpm but I could use a different rpm if I
wanted to I choose whether I'm rigid
tapping or soft tapping by with or
without compensating chunk so with a
compensating Chuck would be a floating
floating top holder and that would be
soft tapping without a compensating
chuck is rigid tapping and then from
there I can do one cut or I can Peck tap
so you're only going to be able Peck tap
if you're in rigid tapping if you're non
rigid having you notice you don't even
get the option because obviously the
soft typing scenario I can't go back
into the hole so we just go one cut how
deep I want to tap I'm going to accept
it and now I want to call up the four
outside positions so again I could copy
and paste that down here but now I'm
managing the same locations to two
different spots or I can use the
position repeat field I just want to pay
attention to the number that was
associated when this when these
positions were built it did that
automatically for me so I just do
position repeat tell the value so I'm
going to tell number one it's going to
show you four holes I'm going to be
highlighted here maybe a little hard for
you guys to see but it just indicated to
you that that's what position one is
going to do I accept it and now as we
simulate we're going to see our four
holes now I'm going to slow speed up a
little bit I can use the ctrl M command
to speed up so now we see we're drilling
those holes and then I tap tap tap
there's our outside perimeter holes
all right so moving on
we've now going to finish our holes so
we're going to come in now in the lower
holes I don't have as much material to
go through so I'm just going to do the
drill reaming function and that's going
to be scenario where it's going to feed
to depth and then pull out the hole so
the dreaming out into the drill option
please that rapid to the hole the
reaming portion visas up and feeds back
out of the hole and then we're going to
call the other set of positions to
finish it up
under drill I want to get to the drill
reaming option and then we'll fill out
this page so I got to go build a
quarter-inch drill so let's go create a
quarter-inch drill again new tool I just
make em all consecutive order certainly
if it's tools were already created in
your library you have to make sure that
they're in the appropriate pocket give
it some name we'll give it a default
length the diameter tip geometry send it
to the program definer feeds and speeds
I have the same option like before tip
or shank so if I want to make sure I'm
breaking through I can tell it now here
I can give it an incremental value or an
absolute so if I looked at my print I
know I am at a half inch plain now when
I drill these so if I want to use a
value like incremental it's the distance
from there to the bottom so that'd be a
half inch plus another eighth so 625
plus the shank should just break me
through if I was maybe doing some kind
of a pre spot drilling operation I could
do that
I've already centered so I don't need to
or if I'm accommodating for a tapped
hole I can give it a little overrun you
fill out the page save it now we're
going to go back to our position repeat
I'm going to grab positions number two
gives me the bolt old pattern we do a
final simulation we have all of our
drilling done so we're just about done
we just got a couple more operations to
go speed it up here so now we see our
four drilled holes if I'm rotate it up I
can see and you can rotate with your
mouse drag it around push down your
center wheel and you can rotate it
around there we see we're just breaking
through trade through our partners
again because we're using that that
selection not tip but to the to the tool
edge so the compensated geometry so once
everything is drilled now we got to do
some slot milling so we're going to jump
back to the milling cycle and we're
going to choose our slotting option it
slots got three different primary
strategies I can do open slots I can do
what we call encapsulated slots that's
where we like a captured key or I can do
these circumferential slots where
they're wrapped around a radius so we're
going to do circumferential slots in
this part from there maybe we'll take a
look at some different types of options
we have in simulation so I can start to
speed up or slow down and you saw me use
ctrl M but you can actually adjust the
overrides directly we can also turn on a
show path if I want to see what the tool
path looks like maybe I want to get a
little better example of what the
physical movement of the cutter is going
to look like so back in our part program
just make sure your highlight is right
here at the bottom just above in the
program we're going to go to milling
we're going to escape back because we
don't want to do any rectangular pocket
commands is we want to do is we're going
to go to the slock command select slot
and here you see is three options for
slots so longitudinal slot would be an
encapsulated slot like a captured key
circumferential so what we're going to
do here in a second and that's going to
be wrapped around a radius or I can do
an open slot and then open slot will be
more like a tricloid little tool path
where I can come through and clear out
that slot geometry so for
circumferential slots we're going to
wrap them around a radius let's bring up
our print so that's going to give me
these two so even if you just had one
you could still use the same cycle
you're just going to tell it down here
when we get there to the number of slots
you have in our case is two I do need to
go get an appropriate tool so if I look
at my print I get a three a slot with I
see that right here in the sectional
view so I got to make sure I use a tool
that's going to fit within that
geometry so go select tool go to our
tool list and let's create a new tool
for that that physical slot so we're
going to select new tool and the mill
and this is going to be probably going
to use like a 5/16 tool in that scenario
that should be adequate enough to get
into the slot just a little smaller than
the 3/8 now in these fields maybe you
don't remember a rough top your head
with the diameter equivalent of a 5/16
tool is you can do basic math so I can
put a fraction and let's say and it will
calculate it for me again number of
flutes especially if I want to program
feed per tooth that's a must if I'm
programming inches per minute with
straight rpm then it's not going to need
that the number of teeth certainly going
to want to give you the diameter because
for our cutter compensation it's going
to need to know it so the tools in again
give it some feed rates same scenario
applies Pieper to if you permit it
simply with rpm I'm going to tell it
what my operation is we're going to
rough it out now when I come to roughing
you notice it popped up an additional
field and that's how fast I want the Z
to come plunging in excuse me
so I'm going to come down 10 inches a
minute and then machine up the
peripheral depending on my material so
she's going to feed into a corner I
haven't already have drilled holes there
so I can feed it in no problem am i
doing a full or a partial so depending
on you know how pending on how the
geometry lands I can do a full picture
or partial if you were just doing one
really couldn't wouldn't matter which
one you chose what's the center of the
feature so what are they revolving
around so in this case two and a half
over two down where does the top of the
slot start from or is it down on a
half-inch pocket so I'm going to leave a
half an inch how many am i doing I'm
doing two so I've a value to there
what's the radius so per the print it's
the same radius of the volkl pattern
to date the starting angle of the first
law and the ending angle the first slot
so if we bring up our graphical view you
can start to see if I plug in numbers
here it starts to move my slots around
alright so we just want to get it where
I want to start my first slot and if I
set this to a 1 we'll only get one slot
so maybe I want to stop well start my
first slot at 3 o'clock so I start a
value 0 I know based on my print my
included angle of my first law to 90
degrees so there I have one slot and
then if I do too since I'm doing full
circle they're going to be indexed
perfectly apart so now I get the two if
I was using the the pitch then I would
have to tell it where the next one's
starting and ending so depending on your
material or depending on your print
shell I say ok slot with 3/8 as we
mentioned before slot depth so
absolutely incremental but if as
incremental it's based on the Z zero
data but my case I using an absolute Pro
the print it's three quarters down depth
per pass we're going to take it on one
cut certainly it would probably be a
little bit more conservative
I was really machining this part do I
want to limit ero for a finish cut I'm
just gonna bring it right to size and
how do I want to position between the
slots just like before with the bolt
hole pattern I could follow the radius
or not I fill it out I'd except there's
no brackets I don't need any more
information so I should be able to
simulate this tool path from here if I
want to see that show path through the
wireframe you're going to use again this
lower expanding key to change the
vertical soft keys all right so I'm
going to click on that until they see
the show path button that's going to
show me all the tool path now it gets a
little muddy you can still leave it on
but use the lead path and that will only
show you the tool path from wherever
you're at moving forward so you can kind
of clean it up if you still want to be
able to see it but maybe I really only
want to see what's going on
inside of the slots so there's my drill
so there's the slots now I see my tool
path in there I can also go into program
control and adjust the speed at which
it's moving so the percentage of
override is not linked to your machine
panel overrides because you can be
concurrently programming or simulating
while the machine is running so it's
actually this field right here so when I
go into the program control vertical
soft key I can move my overrides up or
down and then that's going to change the
speed at which its invites so if I want
to slow it down you can see it starts to
go a lot slower
I can go to 100% which one is at or you
can override it all the way up to 120
120 percent that's going to go super
fast that's the same as me doing the
control-m like I was doing before if you
don't want the path on anymore you can
just toggle it off and I'm going to put
my speed back to 100% that quickly
places the override back to hundred
percent okay
so we're just about there we got to come
in and thread mill and then we're going
to do a little deburring so the thread
mill cycle that's going to allow me to
come in and machine this thread mill
feature now when we get into thread
milling that's going to be found under
milling but we do have to give it our
positions so we're going to use the
position screen and that's going to be
under drilling because you notice
nowhere on this thread milling event
does it ask you the X&Y location of it
this way if I had 30 thread milled holes
to do I could just link this as if I was
tapping them but I wouldn't have to do
different operations at each one now one
of the things I'm showing you here I
always like to make reference to it is
we will calculate the true cutter feed
based off of the a linear feed rate so
when you're given linear feed rate in a
you know referred to you by a tooling
catalog for thread rails that's a
straight linear feed but what happens is
obviously if I'm owed your ID they don't
know the diameter your thread mill tool
the diameter part so they're not going
to give you the true calculated feed
rate so our control will actually
calculate that for you so I program 20
inches a minute I'm going to see that
actually move either quicker or slower
when I run it in auto and it's using
this standard formula so if you're ever
curious what the thread mental formula
is for calculating the actual feed at
the cutter edge because what I need to
know this would be the formula used and
that's literally right out of a thread
mill manufacture catalog later on I'll
have the last slide I have it up there
again to if you if you want to jot it
down or just email me I'd be happy to
provide it to you so let's go ahead and
thread mill so we segue back to our part
and now we're going to come in and we're
going to edit we're going to insert
under milling we're not the slots but
we're going to go to the thread mill and
we're going to fill out our thread mill
cycle I do need to give it a tool so
let's just build our threading tool last
one now here you see the thread mill is
invisible
I have to go to the cutter option and
then I see the thread cutter give it
whatever name I'm just gonna leave the
default depth whatever I know my
diameter beyond my thread mill how many
flutes I have on that thread mill to the
program now we're going to fill it out
the feeds and speeds so here I can use
the Select key and do feed per tooth or
if you permit it remember this would be
a linear feed then the system is going
to calculate based on the cutter
diameter and whether I'm OD your ID if
it has to increase or decrease at feed
rate rpm or con service feed and my
roughing or my finishing we're just
going to rough this out do I want to
work from the top down or the bottom up
when I'm machining is it a right hand or
left hand thread mine's a right hand
is it an ID or OD thread mine's an
internal or an ID now in this case this
is the number of actual teeth or threads
that one revolution of the thread mill
will make so you do need to tell it how
many you have any would be accurate
about this because if you tell it more
it's going to try to do that entire
geometry maybe only one or two
revolutions so you know it's going to
calculate based on the thread geometry
I'm going to give down here how much per
your depth right for the depth of the
thread how much that thread tool would
would accommodate now I give it my depth
of my thread tool maybe we'll let it
thread all the way out so let's say for
argument's sake
I knew mine was a six teeth okay what's
the geometry just like the tap before
what is my ending diameter so remember
we machined in 875 my ending diameter
would be one inch I can give it my
thread height so I know I'm ending at
one and my hole is 875 so we can do a
little math here I can bring up a
calculator if I hit my equals key so I
can say 1 1 is point
seventy-five and that would be a 125 and
then the thread height would be half of
that right so I could do / - I come up
with my 625 is going to be my thread
height and then I hit accept and it
plugs it right into the field for me so
again I can I can type the math in the
field or I could hit equals key if I
want to bring up a calculator my depth
per pass so let's say I go 20 file radio
engagement and obviously machine up till
it gets all over the outside well I'll
limit area for a finish cut oh is you
and if I want control my starting
lead-in I'm timing the thread to
something you had except you can see
it's just like the drill so now I just
have to come over to drilling go to the
position screen and we're just going to
give it the location of the thread so in
our case it's going to do center of the
part but down a half inch so I'll make
sure to tell my Z location for top this
is going to be two and a half over two
inch down I leave the one hole I accept
it now if I simulate it we're going to
see the thread mill come in and thread
mill that feature will speed it up all
right slot oh I went too fast let me
start it again
with drill holes there's your slots and
oh I see I am up in the air oh no I'm
off set this is a good case to maybe put
our path on oh I see so it's down there
so what did I do wrong
sounds like a typo to me
ah I see what is it wrong negative -
that'll do it
accept and everything else should be
good yep absolutely - 1.25 or more
simulate
and there we go
see this run will come down you know get
a you won't actually see that the teeth
per se of the thread but you will see
the toolpath so we can show the path on
if I cleaned it off you'd see just a
little helix that the thread mill does
we can start it one last time should be
them okay so it's going down painting
things up a little bit just jumping a
little further
alright so there is my slops and there I
go there's my little a little path in
there so if I want to get a little
further in I can go into details and we
can use things like zoom let's say and I
can start to see the geometry right in
there so in this case the number of
teeth I was able to do it all in one
shot alright if not I would see a couple
a couple different planes and that again
would be driven really based on the
number of teeth I gave it loops I went
too far back
number teeth I gave it and the overall
it calculates out to be the depth of the
right okay
just about done so here if we come back
we're see where we do a little deburring
real quick so this is just a nice simple
example how I can start to use my cut
copy paste command I can go grab each of
the features and now just pick a new
tool to chamfer and change some very
simple parameters and I can add and
deburring
quite quickly so we're going to deburr
the outside perimeter with the
rectangular spigot we're going to do the
six least three inch counter bore the
nine of the one-inch counter bore the
875 counter bore and we're going to do
the slots as well so I usually will
start kind of from the top down so I'm
just going to grab the finish pass of
the spigot cycle I'm going to copy that
we're going to paste that down here and
then I know I'm going to use the finish
cycle of the pocket the counter bore
let's copy that and paste that and just
I'm going to use the slotting cycle
let's say so we'll just copy that and
paste that down and I want to edit each
of these so I'm going to go grab a tool
now I can build a chamfer mill if I
wanted to as long as I'm not programming
feed per tooth you can actually use
center drills for chamfering or summon
drill definition works pretty well too
so I'm just going to use the center
drill for my chamfering up give it some
speeds and feeds that will obviously be
appropriate for it you got to make sure
you select chamfer and now you just have
to tell it the chamfer sighs that's your
FS so I'm going to do a 25 chamfer and
my insertion down you want to make sure
you insert the cutter at least equal to
but usually a little bit deeper than the
chamber size so I don't roll a burr
I'm going to make that change for each
of those operations so in this case
we're doing the 3-inch counter bore and
we're going to be doing a 20,000 435
chamfer now here are going to make sure
I delete the tool right because I don't
want to have changing to an end mill and
20 and 30 should be fine
simulate and we should now have a
complete part
so I'll just do a quick auto zoom maybe
we'll take the pass off at this point
I'm going to go back to zoom Center it
and now
Peck drilling tapping let's get our
other holes machine our slots thread
mill now we're going to get our chamfer
a nice little corner break around our
three features certainly go back going
to put one in on that feature as well
okay so we have a complete program so
here we're just showing you a few more
of the features that I can do inside a
simulation so I just showed you quickly
the zoom what's nice inside that area is
I also can do a rotate with the buttons
so if I'm on the machine and I don't
have the luxury of a mouse to articulate
the rotation I can pick the rotate view
and move my rotation around with these
keys we also have a sectional view so I
can activate a cut and I can cut out
feature or the model now what we didn't
show you and we're going to be going
into in a later webinar is some of the
advanced cycles so we do have contour
milling and that's what's going to
handle all of our irregular shapes
regular pockets a regular profile so
keep an eye out for that that's coming
in the future
additionally we have a lot of a lot of
advanced commands found under the
various field now one of the most common
ones would be the setting option so what
if I wanted to change one of the
settings that's in my header page
halfway through like I want to change my
retrack value or my safety distance well
that's what the setting page does for
you but here you can access high speed
machining you can call up sub programs
you can do all kinds of set commands
mark and repeat the transition functions
allow it and move my part zero around
either linearly or radially so a lot of
features found within various we're
going to also go into some of those in
the contour milling webinar now what's
also useful when you're starting to
program is sometimes things don't
perfectly fit in the mold of it's a
pocket at the circle it's it's going to
work within a can cycle sometimes the
best way is just doing it a
point-to-point tool path so if you
expand the ha
donkeys over with the gray arrow key you
can access the straight circle command
and in straight circle you can do tool
changes by themselves you don't have to
be inside of a cycle you can just move
the machine around in a straight
geometry or doing circular tool path and
then we can even get into a machine
functions option so I can set like op
stops or program stops and that kind of
stuff so the OP stop the way that would
work is I can insert a page I'm going to
pick either program stop and that would
represent what we're usually more used
to hearing in the industry would be I
can demo one optional stop that's what
we're calling a program stop and then
the stop command is going to be more
like a program stop behavior so the
program stopped on that's going to be
looking for the optional stop flag or to
be set the stop command is going to work
like a traditional program stop so that
means whenever I see it I'm going to
stop so if I want to insert that into my
program it's really as simple as just
kind of picking the point at which I
know I want the machine to stop so maybe
I want to stop it after I do my
counterbore but before I start drilling
and we want to do an inspection point
maybe I know I'm getting a lot of chip
buildup on a stop and cleans and chips
out if that's a problem so just
highlight where you want to insert below
to get to the straight circle I'm going
to hit the arrow over gray key that's
either going to be this soft key on your
display if you have a touchscreen or
you'll see a gray arrow button usually
down to the right of the display that
will expand our horizontal keys over now
you can go into straight circle you see
the vertical keys we were just talking
about pop-up and now I can get into my
machine function so here I can give it
maybe like a program stop and this is
going to force it to stop every time
and what's nice that is it even stops in
simulation so you can even prove out the
optional stops will naps up in
simulation the program stops will so
here you see it comes up to this point
says hey I've got a machine stop
function I now have to press the cycle
start button inside of simulation to
continue on that's the same way it would
behave
in the physical machine if you chose
again if I chose an OPS top scenario
this program stopped now it would just
blow right by it in simulation in my run
mode I got to make sure under program
control that I'm choosing my m0 one ops
or program stop option one that will
make it stop at those command points
now you probably noticed when we were
just expanded off we had a couple extra
buttons give the measure workpiece or
the measure tool field so if you happen
to have the option I have the license
option here in the bottom of screen for
what we call in process measuring so
that we'd be measuring in auto mode so
the Siemens control automatically come
with the ability of doing measuring
commands part or tool in jog but if you
want to do it in auto mode it is an
option by getting the option you get
these cycles not only in G code which
I've talked about in some previous
webinars but we also get it in shot mill
and then from there you have a whole
host of cycles as you see to be able to
measure parts create reports changed
atoms maybe I want to reset my my work
coordinate because my work holding for
my part automation isn't quite perfect a
bunch of different things you can do
here so you can do that both for part
programming and tool probing you know
you can check did I get a chip break I
break my tool do I want to just resize
for wear of my cutter all that can be
done during your program run even in
shop mill now there are some additional
functions I just wanted to kind of
highlight here so we've been talking
about the insert function a little bit
so just to kind of reiterate because
this is an important one just always
remember that wherever the highlight is
she's inserting below that highlight now
another thing it's kind of unique that a
lot of conversational systems don't have
the ability of doing is inserting G code
in the middle of a conversational
program so the inserting G code command
will actually allow you to place any
kind of g code instruction in the middle
of a part program as well the end of
program function has a little bit of
utility there nobody really thinks to
actually open up in a program as if it's
just a basic line but you can actually
turn on a repetition function so if you
have automated work loading or part
loading you can have this automatically
cycle the program and the other one I
like to use a lot is the ctrl G command
and that gives you a quick graphical
representation of the part so that would
be really the same if I
ctrl-g right now I'm sorry going to my
highlight over it it would show me the
geometry and then you see this little
kind of design window of all of the
cycles so as I move my cursor up or down
with my arrows you see that the
highlight changes to whatever event time
on I got to that with a ctrl G or if you
go to edit expand over and go to graphic
view does the same thing so I can either
go over to graphic view or if I remember
the hotkey I can just hit a quick
control G to get into the graphics so
when you get these programs and you're
looking back at them they're starting to
get a little long it's nice to be able
to get a little wireframe representation
so I can kind of see the ops and then
maybe realize ok I just scroll down
quickly because I want to get to this
pot and which he pockets out those so I
see oh that looks like a slot and oh
certainly I'm highlighting my slots so
now we can just close it
oops I close the program sorry I want to
close it with a control G I close it and
then I would be at that corresponding
event so again wherever I leave the
highlight control G and I don't have to
kind of search and try to figure out
what each of the features are
now I can start adding some different
things to my program once I have it
roughed out and one of the things I like
to add I find it makes a little more
readable especially once I'm starting to
run product and I want to kind of get a
better idea of where and the part
sequence I'm in I can add sequence
numbers also if you start to get alarm
messages it's nice it gives you the
exact sequence number that it was in it
makes it a little easier and then just
saying pocket and you go oh boy I have
four pockets in the program I know it's
know it's in 35 pocket so you can go in
and you can start to create sequence
numbers so that's going to be done all
with that edit function like we talked
about and you have two ways you can do a
renumber in command so I can add them if
they weren't already there or
resequenced them or I can have settings
automatically insert them so in the
program it's really just a matter of
being on the edit button expanding our
vertical keys over till I see the
renumber in command
oops must have still been running my
program so I'm in a renumber includes I
tell it what the numbers are so and 5
and 10 and 20 whatever the increments
going to be I say ok automatically
inserts the sequence numbers for me the
settings option if I had this set to yes
then it would automatically build as I
created it I don't usually do that
myself because I find I move a lot of
things around when I'm first roughing in
a program so I like to add sequence
numbers after
couple last things here to show so one
of the areas I like to use the G : for
is adding in operator messages so here I
can actually force a message to pop up
I'll see it in simulation but I'll also
see the run screen by using our message
command so at any point I want to I can
just hit the input button to insert a G
code line and then I'm going to type the
command msg and inside parentheses and
quotations whatever I want my message
display so in this case op one face mail
will be displayed whenever the message
command has been pushed now that will
stay on until I proceed it by another
message or I clear it and clearing it I
would give it the message command with
an open closed parenthesis and that
would clear any previous messages so
just to show you let's say for
argument's sake down here I want to add
just before my drilling I want to add a
message so highlight just above where
you want to insert the g-code line hit
your yellow input key you get the g-code
line type msg open close parenthesis
your self a set of quotes type the
message so so maybe I'm going to call it
drilling drilling ops once that command
is there then you'll notice as we
simulate once that comes up it's going
to stay up for the length of the program
so our machining around you know crank
up my override just a little bit I can
go a little quicker
so we pocket
and we're going to get into the drilling
here it finishes up the pocket so see
the drilling ops on but the drilling app
is not going to go away even though
we've finished drilling it so you would
have to clear that message with the
message clear but you could or you could
just have a new message go over top of
it to see it's going to just maintain
that message for the rest of the length
of the program so if I don't want it to
happen once my drilling is all said and
done you can again a lot of times I'll
just copy the beauty of cut copy and
paste and just get rid of
the message so now as we run it
so it's just going to finish up the
pocket fast-forward it up a little bit
we get the drilling off in and finish up
they see the message goes away that I'm
doing the rest of my ops so you know you
don't always have to obviously be doing
some kind of elaborate g-code
instruction when you're using the g-code
command the message command is certainly
a handy one for that now there are some
other features like adding groups the
groups work nice if I want to kind of
consolidate a bunch of events into a
smaller segment so I'm not looking at
all time so under the build group option
it's really just a matter of giving it a
name for the group and then you'll end
up getting this group with these it will
give you a little plus in the name of
the group you expand it by write our own
over and then you can just kind of copy
and paste which groups you want into
that and you can expand and contract
those groups accordingly now the other
thing we can do if you notice and let me
just jump back to real fast as I'm
simulating you end up getting a cycle
time here once the simulation is
complete but you may actually want to do
a little bit more cycle time analysis so
we have a couple options under settings
you can get cycle time estimates based
on each line or if you apply groups
based on each group so here instead of
just seeing a total cycle time and just
trying to figure out well what
operations really kind of chewing up the
bulk of my cycle time especially if
you're chasing some cycle time you can
turn this on just by changing the
setting for determined machine times and
then it's going to give you my my block
or by group which either one
okay so from that we going to open up to
some final questions I did want to put a
couple frequently asked questions up
here certainly it's common for for guys
maybe to have interested in our key
websites or that support site I
mentioned as well I wanted to display
that formula I talked about so that's
the thread milling feed formula for you
and we do have a couple questions that
came in so first question I've been
programming oh I've been program I step
over with percentage how do I change to
an absolute value if I can okay I did I
did mention that briefly before but it
was kind of brief so what our question
is referring to is like something like a
pocket right
I've been defining my radial engagement
as a step over so if I want to change it
to an absolute value just remember to
hit your select key and it will change
to an inch value but I certainly better
update it because it's not going to be
calculated based on what that percentage
was okay there's an adding an option
like shop mill and 3d require a service
call so generally I would say no most of
our options those including are pretty
much set up right out of the box so it's
a matter of just turning on the license
so you're going to want to refer to your
the machine OEM you know whoever you
purchase it from to see how they like to
handle doing it but in a lot of cases
they'll just give you a simple procedure
you purchase the the option you have to
put in a unique code into the machine a
couple clicks and the option is active
does the feed rate override and
simulation effect program run and I know
it is does not and that's the exact
reason why we're using a separate feed
strategy over our override knobs so this
way you can be running part programs
while you're programming other stuff and
can you save the cycle time report okay
so so you know I was showing you two
different ways to generate that cycle
time real quickly here at the tail end
so if I'm doing it in my run screen or
my auto screen there are ways that you
can actually have it automatically build
a cycle time report for you and that's
actually turned on in the auto screen so
when I'm executing a program and I
expand my horizonte' bozer
go into settings I can do record cycle
time and save them and now it will build
a file for me if I set these two up and
the file just be found in the program
manager area okay so that was I think we
got all the questions so I want to thank
everybody for attending today hopefully
you got a lot out of it if you have any
questions want to follow up want any of
this material please by all means feel
free to reach out to me I would say
email which is on the screen right now
would be the easiest way with that being
said thank you and I look forward to
seeing everybody again in the not so
distant future have a great day bye bye